if you've seen Star Wars Rebels you'll
recognize these strange figures
instantly known as the pergil these
giant space whales can travel through
hyperspace naturally Legends shared by
Harris and Doula in Rebels suggests that
other species first developed hyperspace
travel to emulate the pergil's abilities
we also know from Rebels that the
creatures can be connected via the force
perhaps that's why grogu is able to
sense them so profoundly while the
pergil aren't directly discussed in the
apostates their appearance seems like a
clear setup for the upcoming Ahsoka
series during her Cameo appearance in
the Mandalorian season 2 Ahsoka reveals
that she's hunting Grand Admiral thrawn
who was last seen whisked Away by a
pergil in the rebels finale and since
Ezra's already been confirmed to appear
in the upcoming series it's safe to
assume that the pergil will return
foreign